haben sie es ab jetzt mit armin laschet
an der spitze mit einer gestärkten cdu
zu tun
ich hoffe dass es eine cdu ist die sich
zueinander findet das ist immer gut fürs
regieren miteinander und wir haben ja
noch große aufgaben zu bewältigen nicht
nur wegen der korona krise aber deren
wegen sowieso aber es gibt auch noch ein
paar programmpunkte aus dem
koalitionsvertrag lässt die stärker als
bisher mit der neuen führung mit armin
laschet die zusammenarbeit glaube ich
wird sich weiter gut fortsetzen
ich kann mich da auch nicht beklagen
über die zusammenarbeit mit frau kramp
karrenbauer ich sehe da keinen
unterschied frage ist mit wem sie dann
wirklich zuallererst zusammenarbeiten
also wer ist der erste ansprechpartner
in der cdu ist das ab jetzt ganz klar
armin laschet oder rufen sie eher die
kanzlerin an
ich bin mit der kanzlerin der regierung
zusammen und wir arbeiten im
koalitionsausschuss mit den
parteipositionen fraktionsvorsitzenden
zusammen das klappt ganz gut und die
eifersüchteleien den der cdu
untereinander ausgetragen werden mögen
und mit der cdu die will ich nicht
kommentieren da bin ich auch nicht teil
von gehen sie davon aus sie wollen ja
irgendwann wissen wer wenn sie auf dem
plakat sind werden daneben hängt für die
cdu und csu
rechnen sie damit dass das herr laschet
am ende sein wird oder macht es der
markus söder aus berufung gehen sie im
moment aus sie kenne ihn ja auch
unheimlich gut will er das keine ahnung
und wir werden sehen ich bin da ganz
gelassen weil wir uns von vornherein
vorgenommen haben einen plan für die
zukunft zu entwickeln für die
zwanzigerjahre es geht um respekt es
geht darum wie wir dafür sorgen das
wären 10 20 30 jahren noch gute
arbeitsplätze haben dass wir den
menschengemachten klimawandel aufhalten
können und um ein einiges souverän ist
europa in einer unsicherer werdenden
welt und alles das ist genug um
wahlkampf zu machen wer da gegen mich
antritt das werden wir sehen machen wir
die runde ein bisschen größer und
begrüßen bei uns bei biel zugeschaltet
auch die digital staatsministerin
dorothea die unternehmerinnen und
gründerinnen verena poster hier aus
berlin zugeschaltet und die cdu
spitzenkandidaten aus baden-württemberg
susanne eisenmann in allen schönen guten
abend
dorothee bär ich habe olaf scholz gerade
schon gefragt ob ich nicht für die
spitzenkandidatur in der union ziemlich
wurscht es wäre der cdu-chef wird am
ende macht markus söder würden sie das
denn befürworten und glauben sie dass
erst will bisher das ja nicht gesagt na
ja genau so haben sie jetzt olaf scholz
nicht gefragt
ich frage was vielleicht ähnlich aber
nicht genauso ich glaube das
entscheidende ist dass die cdu sich
jetzt entschieden hat wer sie stört das
ist schon mal ganz wichtig weil wir
haben ja unsere parteivorsitzende
unserer ministerpräsidenten schon etwas
länger an der stelle und wie es halt
immer üblich ist die beiden
parteivorsitzenden werden sich jetzt
sicher über die frage unterhalten wer
die union auch in die bundestagswahl
führt aber das muss nicht direkt am tag
nach dem cdu parteitag entschieden
werden werden wir schon noch etwas zeit
sie haben wir müssen sich die zeit ja
nicht nehmen aber sie wollen sich auch
noch nicht festlegen jetzt für markus
söder frau wer also unsere partei traut
unserem parteivorsitzenden jedes amt der
welt so deswegen sind wir da ganz
entspannt an der stelle